اسلام بيك وسعد الياس ما اهميه هذا
الصاروخ هل من المؤكد حصول ايران عليه على
تطوير صاروخ فرط صوتي تزيد سرعته عن سته
الاف كيلوميتر في الساعه اي اي خمس مرات
الصوت
تجربه هذا الصاروخ كان مفاجئا لانه صاروخ
فرق صوتي هابي سونيك وسرعته خمس مرات سرعه
الصوت ويتطلب تقنيه عاليه وخصوصا في همم
اجلس التوجيه والمحرك
والهيكل القادر على يعني تحمل مثل هذه
السرعه العاليه جدا همم لا شك ان ايران
لديها همم خبره وتقنيه في الصواريخ
والتجارب السابقه تدل على ذلك انما الوصول
بهذا ال- بهذه السرعه الى الصواريخ الهارب
هو امر مفاجئ همم خصوصا ان ال- ال- الحاله
الثوره الايراني وكاله فارس اعلن ان هذا
الصاروخ يصل خلال سبع دقائق الى تل ابيب
وهذه المتداوله حاليا على وسائل التواصل
اجتماعي لكن مساله حرقت دفاعات الجويه
مثلا يعني بحاجه الى نقاش ذلك لان
همم مثلا صواريخ دفاع جوينا سامسونج التي
تحمل البيض الابيض وتحمي مناطق حساسه اخرى
في العالم لا اعتقد ان مثل هذا الصاروخ
يستطيع التجاوزها ولا حتى صواريخ ساد
الدفاع الجوي المنتشره في كوريا الجنوبيه
والتي جاءت واحده منها الى الخليج يعني
امر بحاجه الى نقاش ان هذه الاحداث متطوره
جدا
وهي تزودها بالطائرات المسيره نحن نعلم
طبعا تمتلك صواريخ مماثله
تمتلك مثل هذه الصواريخ واجرت تجذب لها
والصين ايضا اجرى التجربه لصواريخ فرض
صوتيه لكن عمليه التبادل لا اعتقد ان يعني
الطائرات المسيره هي بمستوى مثل هذا
الصواريخ يعني
روسي قادر على تصنيع الطائرات مسيره
ربما يعني اشترت من ايران كميات من
الطائرات لانها لم تكن في دائره
اهتماماتها في دوله قاريه واسعه ولا عمق
استراتيجيه كبيره وجباتها في في اوروبا
واسعه ولم يعني تكون تحسب انها تدخل في
قتال قريب همم يعني همم
ان تيجي تستعمل مثل هذه المسيارات فيه
بستنا انما ال- يعني
التكنولوجيا الصاروخي اهم بكثير من هذه
الطائرات